hallo hallo hallo hallo hallo auto also
ich muss sagen madeira ist geisteskrank
wir sind gestern real top fünf minuten
auto gefahren und sebastian ist direkt
in eine hand rein geplant aber gramm
vollkasko deswegen ist es nicht so
schlimm dreht an gezeigt dass wir so 20
wieso 20 grad oder so haben aber es
fühlt sich deutlich wärmer an wenn kein
wind
der hund ist auch schon wieder weg
das ist die gondel die wir in den
nächsten tagen mal alle anderen leute
die hier so umgehend komplett irritiert
was wir machen hier laufend
offensichtliche touristen und so kameras
und reden mit den kameras hallo hallo
hallo also hier vorne sind tim janssen
carina und buck wie tom ultra schönes
mehr also das meer ist hier und das ist
ultra schön sind so natürliche pools da
waren wir gerade eben drin schwimmen ich
bin so was überzeugt von dieser insel
und ich bin erst ein paar tage da ist
das normal dass manche leute über die
app nicht kein mitglied werden kann
liegt daran dass du google paypal auch
so manche figur
okay das einfach nicht eingerichtet aber
ich dachte vielleicht werden die
einstellungen bei mir also du kannst
nicht einstellen dass die leute nur von
apple kommen also okay das muss eine
leute liegen
es liegt an euch wie groß ist die insel
genauso groß wie das bundesland hamburg
hat simon erzählt
[Musik]
sebastian würdest du sagen das ist ein
qualitätsmerkmal ist wenn man mehr likes
als zuschauer auf seine stream hat warum
wird jetzt der bank sebastian ich habe
die bank kaputt gemacht
[Musik]
hallo hallo hallo
das ding hier hat sich kaputt gemacht im
letzten stream und es ist einfach
repariert jetzt funktioniert einfach
eingesteckt max wird uns jetzt zeigen
wie ihr das dach besteigt ganz genau so
nicht aber sorgen dass bereits einmal
getan dass die haushalts wird er
fahrradfahren okay für wild das haus
wurde in einem tag gestrichen und jetzt
ist es quasi komplett fertig die haben
jetzt noch irgendwas am dach gemacht und
da stehen zwar noch ein paar sachen rum
aber so geil sogar sorry ich hab mir die
anderen von gewitter im kopf gestern
gesprochen die wahren pizza essen und
haben für neun euro sich weiß ich nicht
was für eine pizza bestellt haben eben
die hoch und sehen dass eine drk pfizer
ist noja gehen da hin und sagen hey was
soll die scheiße werden neun euro
gezahlt
wir zahlen nicht so viel für eine
tiefkühlpizza also und wir wissen dass
ich tief gesetzt also sagen sie nein
stimmt nicht ist keine tiefkühlpizza
kontinents in die fläche gehen und sehen
dass es keine ist und dann haben die
also gesagt ey hand aufs herz wir wissen
es ganz genau gesehen die noch die
löcher dienten dieser pc drin sind aber
nicht so gemerkt ja scheiße die wissens
wieder kriegt dann haben sie so gesagt
ja ok bezahlt nur rum cocktails aber
halt die schnauze kommt aviva hd sehen
uns in den kommentaren
man guckt ja die banken selber erzählt
mit dem mofa fahrer
ich bin gern über hochgefahren und bei
soja fakt dass nicht sofort auf weil die
straßen so übertrieben sind und so und
als local er wohnt hier ist ganz cool
und dann freue mich in diese straße dann
ich sags ja lasst mich hier raus da
kommt man nicht durch und meinte nein
kein problem ich komme überall so er
meinte ich meine das unmöglich aber
nichts ist unmöglich von erfährt und
rampe diese smart den spiegel ich
aussteigen okay der einzige abgang ihr
seid echt in unserem bmw die ameisen da
ich ja ja ich bin so angefallen wollen
wir so nach anfangs brennt einfach über
die hausdächer hier
leute wir können schlafen gehen die
wolken sind lila mett igel leute ihr
habt ihr habt gerade meisten max geht
ging so bis hier max 188 groß heißt dass
es mindestens 71 wirklich einfach
geistig geschädigt und muster also ich
würde so nass dass ich weiß gar nicht
was ich was ich sagen soll
[Gelächter]
leo steht dann tanzen einzige tanz
einstellen
das spricht für eine ganztägige arbeitet
seit 2009 10 dabei hat das ist halt auch
so ich ging es halt
aber es war halt von vornherein auch
keinen content geliefert das ist ihr
sagen dass meine mannschaft lässt sich
an einen betrieb aufgenommen hat
unbestritten gelandet nicht das war wir
haben heute auch schon wieder wenn die
hauspreise das siehst du wenn du das
nicht gemacht aber und dann haben wir
erwarten da waren so nah sind runde
basel irgendwie die um dem programm
stehen dann habe ich vielleicht eine so
in den pool geworfen ist ersten
geschwommen und dann ist durch die
öffnung hat ganz schnell wasser gelaufen
dieses runter auf den boden kommt mit
dem google schreibt der kaputt ist und
der bank um drei menschen umfasst darum
selbst zum entstehen
ich will fleisch ja ok und einem montag
hier ist gerade hier darf ich gerade mit
nagel oft zusätzlich geholfen hast du
keine frage motorrad zu beantworten ja
kann ich machen
wie war das damals in der schwarm jedoch
nicht was damals in der schule mit dem
tourette-syndrom was du auf einer extra
schule und dann nicht haben wir haben
die klassenkameraden also ich kann ich
auch der hebelschule nicht ganz am rand
in der hochschule da wird mir eigentlich
jeder angenommen ich wollte nicht
angenommen
düsseldorf rpo ich war uns eine ganz
normale schule auf einer der spiele und
da waren die texte nicht so stark
ausgeprägt wie heute
ich bin aber mal an 12
die hochschulen gewesen war ausbildungen
habe ich ja durchaus angefangen wo
dietrich schon stärker waren die damen
klassenraum was ich nehme an es hat
schon abgelenkt einfach habe ich die
klausuren sogar mit im kasten und
ansonsten nicht warum
ansonsten habe ich die person schon
meinem eigenen raum geschrieben weil ich
da ja wer sich besser konzentrieren
konnten vermutlich die niemand hallo
hallo hallo ich finde ich alle ganz
schnell zerfällt hingegen das werk das
letzte mal vor 26 das ist eine lüge die
noch genau wo aber auch im lauf das ist
metaebene willst du eine take twos netz
kaufen deine seele nicht was bist du für
youtube das wirst du für die youtuber
verkauft seine seele nicht und bist du
quasi kein wollte guckt euch die taxis
angriffen der grüne kumpel die tax wir
sind einfach taxis die noch aktuell
gefahren wären einfach so holte es hat
mercedes-benz wir sind am freescale grad
ich trage fast nie ein bat ich auch
nicht ich habe eigentlich mache ich mir
einmal einen song ist er direkt in den
charts